today on Battle Damage grade kyndra
requested that we test this Jambox a
drop beep boop oh okay okay okay stop
stop the beat stop stop the beat
we know the big jambox can put out a big
sound but can it stainless steel
exterior an industrial weight molded
rubber casing survives some big impacts
this sleek little sound brick will be
subjected to our three tests drop from a
normal height drop from really high and
finally a test of extreme limits will it
live to jam another day let's find out
action cue music
boring totally fine untouched roll
action still playing how's it look here
I mean it's dented badly still works I'm
gonna have nightmares about the Sun we
figured the best way to determine the
strength of our modern-day boom box was
to tested against the strength of an
original boom box that of course we
filled with cement okay here we go
action
Wow cue the music it's like the boombox
blew apart and burst a jam box I'm just
amazed at how toughest thing is no other
device you've ever tested on battle
damage has survived the third test so
we're bringing out the big guns our 55
pound iPhone killing Acme safe roll
action
the safe bounced hahahaha lookit all
right moment of truth this is not gonna
work
cue the music Oh in Denmark we won the
dance competition and we were able to
use the prize money to save the Youth
Center
kaboom let us know what you wants to
test next down there in the comments
below or on social media with the
hashtag battle damage drop that funky
beat then we're so good at dancing